I think by six-year-old granddaughter may have H. Pailora infection. She has constant tummy aches.
She can only eat tiny bits before complaining to be full. She rolls out a little bit with her
mouth, which she swallows. Happened so frequently that she doesn't tell you. But if you ask her,
her answer is yes, just matter of fact. Frequent constipation with occasional diarrhea. Her cut seems
to be a mess. I've read your blog post at H. Pailora and a protocol. You mentioned that dosages
would be different for children. What would they be for a normal size six-year-old? Also,
how would you convince her parents that she needs or H. C. L. when the conventional hospital websites say
the exact opposite? Well, if you have a young person and they have these type of symptoms and you
go, you put them on some sort of P. P. I. or even a thumbs or a roll-aids or something like that to
help her to be. They will get some symptomatic relief because it will decrease the answer to the
stomachs and they'll get less refunds. But they'll think that they're actually solving their problem,
but they're actually making their problem far worse. And setting themselves up for major issues
that could haunt their rest of their lives. So, you know, if their parents are not open to hearing the
truths, it's very difficult to do anything. You can show them my videos, show my blog posts,
and have them do their own research. But if they're very medically minded, there's not a whole lot
to do. We have family members. In our family, I'm full of family of nine, eight out of nine children
myself. And I have so, you know, a couple of my siblings that believed the way I do, but most of them
are extremely medically minded. Some of them married into, you know, families of nurses or doctors
and things. And they, you know, think that I'm just a total black child. So, it's just the way it is.
And you're just going to have to live your life the way you want to live. It's your grandchild. It's
very, very difficult. Most likely, does the child have a child? Yes, it's very possible. But understand
with a child, many times you can solve the problem just getting them on HCl. Maybe just start with
apple cider vinegar. Have the mother give their daughter apple cider vinegar before each meal.
A tablespoon of apple cider vinegar. It's a child will take that. That's going to be a sitting
enough to balance out of six year olds. God. So, if the mother is not naturally minded at all,
or they think grandma is crazy, then it's very difficult to deal with that. I understand. You know,
we have 20-ton grandkids and some of them we don't see very often because of, you know, issues. So,
you just got to keep doing everything you can, keep sharing the truth and hopefully they'll come around.
But if I did suspect H. But H. Marlora in a six-year-old and the parents were very compliant,
I would first treat them with HCl or apple cider vinegar, because many times that will clear it up.
So, you don't need to go to burberry, but quite as it is. If you could get the child,
if the child could swallow pills, then it's easy. If the child will swallow pills, then taking
burberry or garlic and taking HCl and digestive enzymes, if they start feeling better, they're going to
want to keep taking it. And you could clear it up really quick. I will say, though, that if you have a
six-year-old with H. Marlora, she's not the only one in the family with it most likely. So, most likely,
one of the parents have it as well. And because H. Marlora is a bacterial infection that spreads,
you know, very easily through, you know, kissing and it's just very, you know, typically it's
rugs in families. So, I would suspect that there's somebody else in the family that probably has it as
well. As far as how much garlic or burberry to take, most garlic supplements, a six-year-old child could
take one of those burberry supplements. A six-year-old child could take one of those HCl. A six-year-old child
could take one with each meal. They're very good enough to take that. Usually, they're up to 60 pounds
at that side, at that age. They're very good enough to take something like that. If they're really,
really teeny, I'd start with with apple cider vinegar. It's going to be hard to get the child to be
able to buy it if their parents are complacent to not agree with it. So, it's going to be good.